and keep the play alive and now it's Arizona to
Center in Matt Dumba into the zone schz right in
front to haon a shot and hord got over and made
a good save as he read that play well and made a
good body save Justin ful pinches here not enough
of forward support Jordan Kyu there sniffing a
little bit coyotes break in on the two-on one
and Hofer comes across Big Goal Square to the
puck look at that not much room anywhere as it
rolls back for f leaves the Blues in nice time
through two games over 25 minutes hay on the wing
down the Blue's a wrap around by alexandr and what
a chance there and a save by Ingram what a play
by Alexandra and gets down behind the defenseman
but here's that transition pass Kevin Hayes great
patience Alexandra takes it right around boy this
was close great Edge work here look at leaning
into his edges getting it around there gender
just gets his toe out keeps it out of the net
that's a fantastic start it's a I tell you what
it it relieves a headache for the defenseman
when your goalie can move the puck like that
now the Blue's at Center that's grabbed by Faulk
now in the wing cing a shot right on goal and a
good save by Ingram with his right P Dustin faul
joining the attack here Bren Shen makes a great
pass over to Ka in Thea gets across and kicks
the leg up before oh boy it was labeled it's
a fantastic save now Center H High shot again
shoves it over the goal who's trying to get to
it pressured by Arizona and they keep it alive
that Kelly pass in front they score buad with a
rifle into the lower corner and it's one nothing
Arizona as they draw the puck up high they pull
the blues player up high onto the defenseman
once that's committed he goes to the half wall
then boom seen pass and it was open about three
times during that power play you get a big body
in front Logan Krauss can't see around him then
we get a good look here from the Plaza Tire goalie
cam sunquist against
McBain and the face off is won by Arizona
and he felt that one as corko gets it on
the center over skated though and small back
back in dangerous Rock in on goal and they
score ker with a backhander and the St Louis
kid burns the blues again to get that going
but right here Lexi tchenko loses a handle
on the puck and col Paro who's doing as he's
supposed to do get up the ice create that next
wave of offense skates over the puck bl's end
up with nobody back on that one and Clayton K
actually whiffs on that backand H for playing
for the top shelf back hand here staying up
staying elevated deep slot for Cru nice feed
on to Kyu he lost it look out Arizona gets it
pyton comes in short-handed wide open and a
glove save by huler on a short-handed Chant by
m Carone routed right out there at the top of
the paint stays Square keeps his glove in a good
spot steter is back out and he gets in down the
right side shoots it and it's saved by Hofer
on the near side and he covers as the coyotes
had three great chances too short-handed let's
get a good look at the last power play for the
blues it ended up being more shots on goal
for the and that's a break for the blues as
he missed everything now Kevin Hayes back in
shoots it off the glass that rings around to
scandella now right in front Broner shoots he
scores Jacob Ron with a rocket and it's two to
one off the dumpin Kevin Hayes puts it in little
bounce a little bit of a weird bounce there off
the glass Veron comes in gains the middle of the
ice uncontested look that's wide open through the
middle of the ice and he's going to rock
it for a wrist shot beats Ingram over to
the blocker side this is a big big big momentum
changer for the blues cleaned up there by Tucker
now A Center Sun twist in the area he never
really got it Arizona back in and a shot they
score what a shot through the legs of Hofer by
carcone that's a great goal by Carone it's now
3-1 assisted byos sunis just missing the
pucks driving in wide there on Tyler Tucker
slides at five hole again mean this is a good
strong move to the net and it just just gets
greasy underneath the pad you can see the
reaction Thomas after it along with Brandon
saw and the coyotes come to Center schaltz he
gets it back on the give and go in front that
was intended for Moser blues lose it comes in
front schaltz wide open shoots and he scores what
a backhander by schaltz in Arizona with a 41 lead
but again Coyote's in on the four check here schz
does a good job watch this here Keller with that
he loads it up like he's going to shoot it then
schz gets a step on Tory Krug out of the corner
here as it goes off to skate right to Keller
who makes a fantastic Play Turn and they burn
the puck goes from their goal line to Center
ice and Into the Blue Zone in a hurry so br's
going to have to do a better job of managing
that pu down low and now for Matias melli he
gets it back again melli in the circle one time
Tim and they score as hord got across but not in
time that was zooker with a one timer and it's
51 coyotes go from that defenseman to the half
W and then looking to feed it through the scene
but this is an exceptional pass and a great one
timer Joel huler gets a piece of it but it still
cars into the net big neighbors elevated up there
with the Bren Shen line and I saw Lexi turenko
had to move down with sun TST we'll see if Craig
Ruby has any other changes jaob BR in front they
score Sammy bla on a great feed and bl makes it
[Music] 52 fantastic play on the second goal
great move to the neutral zone sticks with it
Sammy Blake goes to the dangerous area and then
right there Jacob Vera threading the needle here
bouncing Puck goes from glove to the ice and
then feeds it through the triangle right to
Samy BL drops the knee finds it back of the net as
neighbors tries to sneak in there he was knocked
down and Arizona counters with melli and now
for cooling to the net for zooker a shot and a
save by Hofer he's down it's still loose there and
knocked to the boards but uh he can shoot the puck
and love to shoot the puck does saroo now it's
stolen by McBain all alone and a save by Hofer as
Tucker lost it and that was McBain who picked his
pocket and had a great chance it's not a bad idea
you get a guy that's running around out there the
game looks to be out of reach you don't want it to
get out of control the officials doing a good job
there dery comes in shoots he scores what a shot
by dery on the power play their third power play
goal tonight and it's 62 lose the face off just
walks right to the middle of the ice uncontested
and snaps that one home Joel Hofer with the screen
right there you can see taking the eyes away from
the golender how much that matters right here I
felt like casber C probably should have been in
the middle of the ice on that one and you can see
right here my goodness yeah you can almost feel
the energy kind of get sucked out of the building
on that one certainly the blues players were
wearing it too so that was a big Turning Point the
game and the final score 62 as Arizona goes to 2
and2 on the year the blues fall to one one and one